valentina clambers into what's left of
her apartment
the seventy-year-old has lived in
mariupol since she was born
what do we do now she says i don't want
to leave but there's nowhere to live
here
it's thought 160 000 people are trapped
in the besieged and destroyed city but
on monday ukraine did not open proposed
humanitarian corridors blaming russia
for what it called provocations along
escape routes
but just as peace talks are set to
resume in turkey news reports that two
ukrainian negotiators one of them an mp
and russian oligarch roman abramovich
suffered symptoms of a suspected
poisoning after talks earlier in march
the men reportedly complained of eye and
skin irritation i'm not surprised
unfortunately
and i think that russia has no regard
for human life and it will continue to
use tactics like this to scare people
the wall street journal reports russian
hard-liners are suspected to be to blame
in the past two decades russian
opposition figures and defectors have
been poisoned
[Music]
most recently the now jailed russian
opposition leader alexey navalny in 2020
the kremlin always denied involvement it
all only adds to tensions ahead of talks
in the wake of a significant offer from
vladimir zelinsky
the ukrainian president saying he is
willing to discuss the neutrality of
ukraine subject to a referendum this is
a real concession on the ukrainians part
but it won't be just uh neutrality it
will have to be accompanied by western
security guarantees and this is a really
sticky issue in other words somehow be
protected from invasion without being
inside nato but before all that the
russians would first need to leave
ukraine in moscow the kremlin described
u.s president joe biden's suggestion
that vladimir putin be removed from
power as alarming remark biden was
unapologetic for saying it was him
expressing his moral outrage dallas
redmond shannon in london thanks